hello everyone and welcome to yet
another game from the final round of the
2019 us championship this is most likely
my favorite game from the entire
championship play near dominguez Paris
has to win this game to at least well
tie for the first place with Nakamura
and Timur Gregg not having the greatest
tournament so far but as I've already
said his games are often the most
enjoyable ones but with with great
excitement in games you know you don't
often get a lot of points but yeah it's
a really anything game and it really
shows what what what a rage game chess
is so I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it now
some of you may know Timur Karev as the
blindfold King he will often play for 40
50 people in a blindfold simultaneous
exhibition winning pretty much most of
the games and also if well if you
haven't seen I believe it was in
November last year he did he jumped out
of an airplane with a chess board
there's we do have a nice photo of this
dare we have it there steamer Guerrero
jumping out of an airplane with a chess
board also wearing what appears to be
you know a checkered clothing so we can
definitely say the team or girl really
loves chess and although it's a it's a
really interesting feat could also be a
bit dangerous I mean what if he drops
the chess board it could hit someone in
the head or or am I missing something
you know if that if that were to happen
you you could have a headline in the
newspapers tomorrow you know it's not
like just never killed anyone a question
mark or some weird title like that but
it's hard to say he might have have had
it glued to his hand or he might have
dived over an unpopulated area so either
way I mean however you put it very very
nice jumping out of an airplane with a
chess board yeah I forgot well if you
want to see the entire jump there is a
video recording of it I will put a link
to it in the description below first
thing you will see just click on it and
enjoy a nice skydive Oh buddy I'm
getting back to this game a linear
Dominguez vs. team or Karev Karev
Dominguez has to win this game and he
opens with E 4 we have c5 by Karev
Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and the d4 the Sicilian is
on the board we have C captors Knight
captures nice to have six Knight to c3
and now d6 a nice classic Sicilian we
have f3 by white enforcing the center
with E 5 kicking the knight back Knight
b3 and Bishop to e6 this is all very
standard stuff and Knight to d5 just a
nice centralizing move where of course
you can trade but you don't really gain
anything from it you can't trade with
the night because of course you will
lose the piece sorry about that and of
course if you trade with a bishop then
very early on in the game you will give
up the bishop pair so simply continuing
Bishop to e7
we have c4 by white grabbing further
control of the d5 square with castles
by gaurav and the now comes Bishop to e3
and here already a very interesting move
by gaurav a5 allowing White's the
seemingly take control of the b6 square
and it seems very dangerous for example
brush would be six attacks the Queen
Queen b8 you could go Knight c7 attack
the rook on a eight but here black can
get a very nice game for example Knight
d7 you give up the exchange Knight
captures Queen captures now you have to
move the bush back as it's attacked
Bishop to e3 and now with a four black
will get a lot of play for for this
exchange early on 92 or c1 for example
and f5 black immediately bust open the
center and white still has to make at
least two moves to Castle and all of the
black's pieces are you know very very
organized and ready to jump on the
attack towards the book to what at the
white king so after this a5 move of
course nothing of the sort happened we
have Queen to d2 Dominguez simply
continues developing we have a four
pushing the knight back
nice the c1 and now comes nice to d7
making room for for this f5 maneuver a
lot of you have said that lately you
will often see an arrow before I
actually do the arrow it's it's an
interface glitch that they still haven't
fixed so not a lot of things I can do to
avoid it there are some things I can do
to avoid it for example after I prepare
a game I can like restart the entire
interface or something but
sometimes I forget and then you will
have this arrow before an actual arrow
should be there so sorry about that
Knight to e2 by Dominguez and now f5
white white king is still in the center
so of course Gaurav wants to start an
attack he captures an f5 by Dominguez
Bishop captures on f5 and not night e to
c3 just gaining further control of the
d5 square and now the bishop can also be
developed white can castle and so on
Knight the c5 by black with Bishop to e2
preparing the castle and now just a nice
little check before before seeing what
what will happen
Dominguez blocks it with the g3 with
Bishop to f6 and now rook to d1 it's
hard to say if the check was actually
useful or if the g3 pawn helps white in
some way obviously guru decided that it
was a weakening of the position and of
course any move by the pawn in front of
the King it is a weakening of the
position unless it's not but okay
Knights the e6
and here we have castles you can't win
the d6 pawn it's also a very nice idea
for example you could play Knight
captures with the Czech Queen characters
and grab the d6 pawn but then you have
this problem of a3
what a3 does is it takes away the escape
square from the White Queen and now if
you don't react to this black will just
capture the b2 pawn and if you react to
this with b3 then look Fe a rook F da
twins the Queen now you can see that the
night covers the c7 squared the night
covers the c5 square the c6 knife covers
the b v square and now there's a pawn on
a3 so the White King the Queen cannot
escape so you would well easily blunder
the Queen here which is not something we
want to do in a final round of the US
Championship but okay after Knights the
e6 we have castles by white you know
safety first and now Knight see to d4
with Bishop to d3 not allowing this this
trade to happen of saving the light
square bishop and now comes Bishop to h3
grabbing yet more space on the King side
forcing the rook to move rook to f2 and
now Bishop to g5 garea wants to trade
trade
the Bishop's here and he wants his h3
Bishop to remain on such a nice diagonal
Bishop to f1 opposing the LightSquared
Bishop Bishop captures with rook
captures now doubling rooks on the F
file but strip captures Queen captures
and now gotta have goes for rook to c8
he goes after the c4 pawn and this is
one of the nicer moments in the game
here you could try and defend it
what's a queen d3 now unite C firewood
an attack on the Queen the Queen has to
go back black gained some gains some
momentum but here the critical idea is
f4 and this is indeed what Dominguez
played so what do you play here without
much thinking Karev did go for the c4
pawn he played rook captures on c4 again
with the arrow and it's a really
interesting moment in the game here F
captures on e5 was played but here I was
a I was watching the life coverage and
everyone went crazy like yeah white is
winning here but you know how is white
winning here that's the important
question so if you would like so free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what you would play here with the white
pieces it's a very very tricky engine
line so if you feel like it you know go
right ahead
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
supporter of engine lines and for those
who just wanna enjoy the show not F
captures an e5 the move Dominguez played
but f5 this is the idea and now after
Knight g5 threatening Knight to h3 to
pick up the rook first you play King g2
taking away the h3 squared from black's
knight and now it appears that there is
no good defense against f6 this is the
point but you know first you have to see
f5 then you have to see the tricky sound
and move King to g2 and then you give
black any move black once and still
you're just gonna play f6 and you will
claim that you are winning
for example whatever black plays you
will go f6 you will cut off the Queen's
defense towards the Knight Queen
captures Knight is a threat pawn
captures g7 opening up the double rooks
with check it does seem that black would
have well either either an extremely
difficult time here
or just a lost endgame again as Karev
was also very low on time here I blow I
believe below three minutes okay it did
not happen in the game the domain
displayed f captures on e5 and now comes
Luke captures on f2 rook captures and
now rook the c5 pressuring the knight
here because if the position opens up
then the queen will also be pressuring
the night along the D file a very nice
move and also the knight cannot move
because then you would lose the e5 point
so King to g2 first not allowing any
tricky moves with the knight improving
the position of the king we have h6 by
grave h4 and now Knight to see tonight
back to c6 pressuring d5 pawn so now you
do have to capture and it's very
interesting
karev still very very low on time here
and he has still to make 10 moves to
reach time control we have Paul captures
Queen captures not with a double attack
against the knight and here Dominguez
plays look the d2 and now you have the
this huge threat of Knight to f6 check
winning the Queen so how do you prevent
this ogre F played the absolute best
move he played Knight C to D for which
is not all that clear because well white
can just capture it and give up the rook
for two nights but with so so little
time on the clock guard ever figures it
out
Dominguez after thinking about the
position for quite some time
not quite some time he didn't think a
lot of obviously he captured the night
it's the strongest move he played rook
captures Knight captures Queen captures
and now Graf has a look for two nights
and he only has one good line here and
there's still the threat of 90 to f6
check winning the Queen or if Queen
captures and f6 you will win the rook
and c5 so really feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the line and
graph so when he decided to give up the
two knights for the rook it's really
just what a wonderful line I'll give you
a couple of seconds we'll have a nice
sip of water have a bit of a sore throat
for those of you who were able to do it
you are just an amazing player such such
much like the blindfold King and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show a three here you had to find that
Knight to f6 isn't a problem for black
well it is a problem but it's the best
black has the meanest play Knight to f6
check and now you will either capture
the pawn and lose the Queen
sorry capture the knightwood opponent
lose the queen or you will play Queen
captures and lose the rook which
happened in the game we have Queen
captures rook and now Graf played pawn
captures pawn and b2 and now white is up
a knight but you do have this problem of
this point already being and B - so what
do you play here domain display 25 check
with King 288 and now comes Knight the
b1 blocking if you try something like
Queen d3 guarding the knight and the B 1
squared then Queen captures on c3 is the
problem if Queen captures you get
another Queen into the game with equal
material on the board white cannot allow
this so here we have this position night
b1 Dominguez is up a knight and he he
has to win this game if he wants to
become US Champion and it's not all that
clear how you will do that
Queen to g6 attacking the knight we have
Queen to d1 protecting the night and now
just Queen to e4 check we have King to F
to Queen to f5 check a King goes back G
to Queenie for check and King to h2 if
this was any other game I'm sure maybe
the minister would agree that this is a
draw and he would not push but like I
said he has to win this game if he wants
to be the 2019 US Champion so of course
he has to do it but unless this Knight
can somehow enter the game it's not all
that clear how you will how you will win
this game with with just the Queen
that's pretty much stuck guarding the
knight on B 1 so we have Queen to a5 now
comes h5 by white and Queen to f2 check
King h3 Queen a5 check King go urn and
now g4 Quinta efore check and now comes
the king to g3 and not allowing any
perpetual with b5 now by black a3 and
now even before black wants to trade off
White's the last hope of pushing
something we have a captor son before
Queen captures on b4 and now comes Queen
to d8 check King to h7 now comes the
Queen to d3 check King goes back to h8
and now Queen to f5 from f5 Queen guards
everything all the pawns protects the
King guards in item b1 but how do you
advance with the white pieces Queen to
d4 by Karev with King to f3 King to g8
and now comes the King to e2 now the
White King will try to help out with the
attack against the b2 pawn king back to
h8 now comes the King back to f3 King to
g8 and now Queen to ecigs width check
King to h8 now comes King to e2 and now
King back to h7 Queen to a5 check with
King to a traitor now comes Knight - d -
finally Dominguez is able to activate
the night but can deny to go any further
with Queen to c3 now preparing to to go
Queen Queen to C 1 and X well supported
the advancement of the pond to be won if
the Queen ever moves from this diagonal
guarding b1 but now the Mingus finds a
plan we have Queen to f8 to check King
to h7 Queen to f5 check King to h8 and
now Queen to b4 with with some very nice
ideas King to g8 by grave and now comes
Queen to d5 check King to h8 Queen to d8
check came to h7 and finally dominguez
manages to trade Queens we have Queen to
d3 width check but Queen captures we
have King capture son d3 sorry and
they're not just g6 King to c2 we have
King to g7 and 1994 pawn captures pawn
captures and now King to f7
Dominguez tries to create a wall against
the black King so the black King cannot
approach the white pawn on h5 but the
path is pretty clear it will be very
hard to prevent this we have King
capture son B to kink the e6 and now
King to c3 and now if black can somehow
eliminate the the pond and the game's
over you cannot win a game with with
just a knight
King to f5 now comes in to d4 defending
the knight we have King to g4 and now
Knight to f6 check so feel free to pause
the video here one last time and what do
you play here with black how do you hold
this I'll give you a few seconds if you
played any other move that King to f5
for example if you play the King here
King here King here then you would lose
the game King to f5 is the only move for
example if you try this
it seems that yes you are attacking the
knight and the pond but King e5 and now
you have to go back for example you have
to go here King goes here you have to
move further back King goes here and not
here obviously you will lose the pawn a
white will promote the pawn and win the
game easily so King to f5 this is what
Gary have played this is the strongest
move and now the knight has to move
Knight to e4 is played King to g4 again
attacking at the point Knight f6 check
King f5 and now Knight the ea8 Dominguez
will try not to guard the point from
from the other side King G five nights
the g7 again defending the pawn but King
f6 attacking the knight we have nice to
e8 check King g5 nice to g7 and here
after King to have sex finally unmoved
set 77 domingus agreed that there was no
way that he can push this for a win and
they agreed to a draw which is you know
quite unfortunate for Dominguez who
played a brilliant tournament and as you
can see finished in the second place
ahead of Fabiana Caruana
obviously better better anti breaks a
half a point behind he Cara Nakamura if
if he was able to win this game against
Karev Karev did not create such a
masterpiece over the board he would be
tied with Nakamura and then we would
have playoffs and it would be it would
be very interesting it's hard to play
player you know faster time controls
against Nakamura but with such an
excellent tournament I mean gets played
I'm sure it would be really really
impressive but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed that I really enjoyed
it it really has I enjoyed chess games
that have us
taury to it here it always seemed like
Dominguez will break through break
through break through and then just
Korea found that a three move with a
rook sacrifice that stranded him with
being down a piece but he was able to
pull it off really really in the price
of it achievement by Timur Karev once
again if you're interested to check out
his jump from from the airplane with the
check board first link in the
description below its it's quite nice
also second link in the description
below check out the trailer for the
grantee chess classic if you still
haven't really impressed with chess
footage just awesome stuff I would like
to thank once again George
chatzi georgiou your brain Schmidt
Marcus Tveit Allen ferns and Michael
Hildebrand for conversion to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
one more game but from the women's US
Championship as also some very
interesting stuff happened there and
yeah we're continuing with what we do
usually we'll be checking up on the
under gosh team of Memorial continuing
the Capablanca saga as soon as I catch a
break and you know just enjoying
whatever we can so thank you and I will
see you soon enjoy the rest of your day